this is the perfect segue into truth
over facts oh yeah that's it is a good
segue right over truth over facts I'm
sure you people have heard this oh how
many of you have seen the epic truth
over facts this is this is I'm sorry man
I don't know if you guys watch segmented
earlier I gotta say so funny this is one
of the greatest trolls ever done yeah
and I don't know like you know I don't
want to say that the Trump campaign did
all of it on purpose like the outcome
was just a perfect storm in some regard
but it really was a smart campaign yeah
let me give you the gist I know that
this is a website called the truth over
facts dot-com when you go there you see
a very confused looking Joe Biden
actually several of them and it says Joe
Biden files text truth text truth to
8802 to if you have any tips related to
discovery of truth over facts paid for
by Donald J Trump first it's so
obviously not real right I'm so I can't
it's just so difficult
the journalists thought it was real they
started tweeting about it
Trump's truth over facts campaign said
as recline was like if you would have
told me that Trump was gonna launch a
campaign called truth or facts I would
have said you know that was unreasonable
and unsubstantiated but here we are
something like that so they they
actually thought that was his new slogan
like that like I was doing some kind of
new campaign or something yeah no more
Mogga
let's just do truth over facts first
this is a gap from joe wonderful it's a
it's a gather some Joe Biden I know Joe
Biden was in Iowa or something and he
said we believed in truth over facts and
everyone's are making fun of him the
right Lisa it's crazy
how do all these political reporters not
know that where have they been
yeah what what are they reporting on
yeah what what's going on that's crazy
man that doesn't make any second I can I
can cite numerous Biden gaps on top my
head or like weird circumstances yeah
got what was it them corn pop thing
yeah court much you know the thing you
know
thing there was the the thing on stage
where he turned around and put his back
to the camera and people thought he was
lost but I think he was fixing his teeth
how about this one how about this one
the way almost where it looked like fell
asleep on TV that was my favorite yeah
that that one you got it there was there
was that one easiest one to do the 21
second clip where he sputtered and
muttered randomly on CNN it's like uh if
you if you pointed these things out to
me I'd be like I remember that day care
yep the like hair thing the kids they
make cartoons about it I try to forget
that part sure there were facts like one
of the ones I don't want to remember
there's I I just learned this though the
Winston Churchill thing I didn't know oh
did you know those of you listening did
you know that at at a CN I was a PBS
debate that someone said to Joe Biden at
the end of your first term you'll be 82
you will be the oldest president in US
history he says what about Winston
Churchill and he didn't he didn't
hesitate at all no he was like he's
ready
what about Winston Churchill and then
the guy says American history and he
goes American history oh I was joking I
was making a joke that's a joke and
everyone laughs it's like no he wasn't
are you worried I don't know so so not
only listen listen not only did they not
even know about Biden's gaffe which to
me is kind of crazy like you have one
job your job is to cover politics and
you don't even know about a high profile
gaffe which turned into a major meme
yeah the right was going nuts about on
Twitter yeah when I was on when I was on
Rogan with Dorsey and vag I got a and
and Joe we were talking about how in
2016
left-wing journalists don't follow
right-wing journalists but right-wing
journalists follow both left and right
right that makes sense
Jack said it was getting better like
it's changing its changing I disagree
and I think Lydia disagrees - I do I was
making a face like this yeah that's not
happening that is not changing that it's
not getting better
sorry I'm a faces the reason and this is
proof if you follow any conservative you
would have seen truther effects light up
your Twitter feed like crazy mm-hmm none
of them knew what this was you know what
gets even crazier Oh enlighten us didn't
Google like all you had to do was do
type it in and this pops up and it's so
obvious come on didn't even do that come
one job to Google things this is crazy
yeah and I was talking about this I
don't know stalking was in the last show
or whatever how you know one thing that
I'm gonna start to start doing soon is
like a news aggregator slash fact
checker the goal so you have a lot of
these fact-checking websites where it's
like you can't really navigate it it's a
fact check right so you're not seeing
stories you're seeing like you know
claim claim claim false true false I
wanna make an actual site where it's
like you know Donald Trump launches
truth over facts satirical campaign yeah
mocking Joe Biden and then when you go
into it it shows you sources edit
history it shows you all these other
sites and what the mainstream media is
saying to give you an actual
understanding of what's happening I
actually think there there's been a few
chat comments randomly that I've caught
people are asking for this for you to
make this what isn't it crazy you gotta
do it hold on listen listen it makes
sense in this climate and I not world
that we've got it's like we need to the
plants the plant for love it the next
plan is boom ah I'm gonna eventually we
need a space yeah but then the goal is
to get several people and what we'll do
is there'll be big high-profile stories
the day probably all there's a lot other
stories that I do commentary on okay and
we're gonna fact like I do a fact check
on most these stories anyway to some to
varying degrees yeah and then we'll have
a breakdown of like we've confirmed this
story from these different sources all
independently confirming it right and
then we'll show these nice edit history
and we'll explain like here's what
happened but also there will be like an
analysis like in the truth of a fact
story journalists were clueless as to
what really happened and it'll be it'll
be something that effect but the point
that I'm bringing up and why think this
is crazy why do we need that website we
can't even trust the news articles the
news companies right because they don't
fact-check any of it that's true one of
the guys who tweeted like this was a
long to like what is this I don't
understand you don't trust your trust to
facts anymore what does Trump trying to
say senior national correspondent for
ABC News Wow yeah how do you not know
that yeah how do you not go like I see
this thing Trump is doing
let me type that in real quick to Google
yeah oh you're not clearly satire hmm
they don't it's pretty clever I
at politican a couple years ago and
there was a panel with the guy from
Media Matters
david pack knows on it a couple other
people and remember who lauren chen i
think ok and we all asked it was a Q&A
session and i went up and asked how are
we supposed to you know trust these
outlets when they don't even have fact
checkers anymore they fired them all
they don't they don't do it and I got a
really awful response but it was funny
because it was supposed to be like a
fake news panel or something and they're
like well you know the job of the
journalist as they're writing is to
fact-check the news and I'm like man I
you guys have no idea you're dying about
that's clearly not the case
you know fact checkers are independent
for a reason right so that when the
journalist writes the story someone from
a different department at a different
floor make several phone calls and says
is what they're claiming true right that
way if you have one person who's in
charge of their own fact-checking
they're gonna just lie oh man or find
the ones that fit what they're trying to
say right yeah oh well I found all these
articles seems like yeah well are they
true or do you dig your hole more you
know do you remember that story about
that was like I think was a German guy
who won a bunch of awards he wrote for
like Newsweek time or like Der Spiegel
and it turned out everything was just
fake yes I do remember that yeah I
remember this guy he was like one of
their most esteemed reporters he'd been
reporting for like 10 or 20 years or
something and it turned out yeah every
single thing he had been pulling out of
thin air and there was absolutely no
basis to it oh my god their best
reporter system has it Der Spiegel says
top journalists faked stories for years
publication says cloths roll odious
committed journalistic fraud on a grand
scale you know it's really funny about
this
everything technically he didn't because
what he did is commonplace like I say
it's on a grand scale yeah it's like
what do what do you mean he's like does
everything what everyone else does he
got caught that's what it really is poor
fool it's funny cuz I remember when the
story was coming out people were like
why would a journalist make up sources
in lie that makes no sense absolutely
well when you wouldn't a you know what
does the Pulitzer Prize pay like ten
grand
it definitely pays money so much I think
so I think it pays ten grand I'm gonna
google it
this it's a nice little sum of money
yeah see you can cool things that's how
this works
ten thousand but fifteen thousand
dollars not bad the Pulitzer Prize
awarded yearly in 21 categories in 20 of
the categories each winner receives a
certificate and a fifth US $15,000 cash
award rate adjusted for inflation yeah
it went up from second so let me tell
you when someone writes a story and wins
a Pulitzer they put money in their
pocket come on man it's so obvious why
they write fake news to monetize the
first reason you make money man sweet
sweet scrilla baby you write a fake
story Adam Craig ler does a triple
backflip off the back porch
boom 1 million views it's shrimp shrimp
quadrantal best backflip I've ever seen
on a skateboard Wow ripping into a right
kick flipped as I spun it was he did it
because he was saving a falling puppy so
here you write a story like that can
someone do that picture please you a
ridiculous picture you fit the narrative
they're clever about it but you'll get
all these you got all these hits you
sell all these ads you make all this
money yeah and then the next day you say
oopsy
oops Oh oopsie listen see bye
triple backflip catching the dog in a
cat I meant I fell you know it was in a
video that's all but there was a cat in
my head while I was playing they don't
know I was petting it's no it's not so
overt they don't they don't you know
they won't write a story where it's like
you know Adam did triple backflip
they'll write something more believable
like you saw with the New Statesman art
I was just saying like the you know
talking about Ivanka and it's like it
wasn't saying anything for certain if
there was no facts that she even spoke
of it was just like assumptions and
hearsay nothing oh I got a bunch of
nothingness I got a good one for you oh
good so I have a Google Alert set up for
you know various things okay including
myself and I get notifications when
people
right stories about me okay one of them
was a journalistic advisory website
mm-hmm and it was written by this
left-wing activist posing as a
journalist who tried to get the proud
boys banned from their banking
institutions successfully actually did
get the prod boys band she had sent an
email to Chase Bank saying something to
the effect of like why are you providing
support for these groups or something
it's like providing support is such an
awful way to phrase someone opened a
bank account at one of your branches
it's like a ridiculous thing to say that
thing that anyone can do yeah I was a
merchant account so it was like there's
probably tens of millions of them they
come be had no idea will they purge the
proud boys like the guys personal
account it wasn't even to probably kind
of close down his personal account so
she writes and she writes you know like
how to deal with hate speech in this in
this thing and then she says let me give
you an example from my own history when
you know far-right adjacent bloggers Tim
Poole a popular YouTube or you know
published an email of mine blah blah and
I'm like what is far-right adjacent mean
does that mean right-wing does that mean
just regular right-wing why would you
write far-right adjacent instead of
right I think it means right you're in
the center which is next to the right
yeah you're also far left adjacent then
here in the middle talk about that the
the right is adjacent to center right
and far right okay so if your far-right
adjacent the only thing you could
possibly is right possibly be is right
so there's nowhere further to go so the
reason she wrote forward adjacent is to
make it sound more ominous yeah a
far-right adjacent popular youtuber
that's right libertarian socialist Tim
Poole social liberal all that gesture
because I don't like the Democrats but
that that's that's what she she does
that because it's shocking it's a
narrative it you know it'll it'll be
like woo prestige and like you know
allure this crazy story an attitude
flare so how seriously but that's it
right yeah a story about you being
called out for malfeasance and
wrongdoing yeah that's not gonna get a
lot of clicks but if you're being
attacked by a hate mob sparked by far
right adjacent bloggers now we're
talking and it's technically not untrue
it's her opinion and masquerading as bad
yeah and it makes her a victim hmm so
the journalists can do is I love I love
framing devices my favorite one is
hydroxy acid yeah III know this is great
yeah so most of you already know this
but I always the example I give people
is that hydroxy acid is a is it
relatively dangerous substance if you
breathe in a little bit of it you could
die they use it to like clean down you
know clean off you know metals it
actually eats through metal it's used in
nuclear power plants and it's
responsible for a lot of deaths every
year they actually find it in cancer
cells and then once people are all
freaked out you just say like you know
this is a very serious problem I could
have written all that down as fact but
then when I tell you that it means water
hydric hydroxy acid means water mmm-hmm
it's the same thing is that dihydrogen
monoxide hoax but I just hydric acid
sounds crazier in my opinion sounds you
know acid yeah very scary oh here's
here's my favorite my favorite retelling
of this I did this video a few years ago
this is everything I'm about to tell you
guys is the truth 100% true you're gonna
love it
you ready no wait hold on let me uh
adjust my seat okay I'm ready now now
already here's how here's how I handle
the framing and I'll explain everything
after I do it first do you know what
chemtrails are yes the planes right that
that that vapor that's coming out of
them yep yeah a lot of people think
these chemtrails are nefarious they you
know they do a lot of things negative to
us and the planes are spraying them out
mm-hmm I used to work for American Eagle
Airlines okay which is the regional
branch for American Airlines and we
would load these planes up but we
handled baggage right yeah so I was an
acting crew chief which a man that
periodically I'd be in charge of whole
teams but you know it's like a mix like
you're not quite a crew chief or you in
charge but you're you're one step up
from a regular crew member okay and
there would be people who would come out
in big vehicles and pull out a hose hook
it into the plane and pump in hydroxy
acid into these planes now this is a
chemical it's serious right oh my god
it's the hydraulic the truth hydroxy
acids pumped into these playing 100%
true by the way what I've sent troops I
watched that I watched them do this yeah
okay mm-hmm
and I didn't know what the point of
putting this hajeck hydroxy acid in the
plane was and that's true this is true
and I'll explain and so this this stuff
is used in nuclear power plants it can
eat through metal
it's found in cancer cells if you
breathe in even a little bit you die you
know and so let me tell you though I
know this for a fact when you see those
planes flying when you see plane flying
and you see that vapour trail coming up
that is vaporized hydroxy acid humming
out the back of that plane the truth
that's a fact
well that is 100% it is a vapor of it I
can confirm this as somebody who worked
for the airport thank you Tim so I mean
I use it I use it so I didn't I did
several things in here I used framing
devices to make it sound ominous you
know and I used assumptive language to
make you draw connections I never said I
never said the vapor coming out of the
plane was was the same stuff they loaded
into it I said they put it in the plane
and when you look at look up and see it
that vapor coming out is hydraulic
hydroxy acid that makes the average
person assume it's the chemical they put
in the plane it's not the contrail comes
from condensation and when it you know
pulls in water vapor and then pushes it
out in the vapor cloud so it is
vaporized hijacked water when I said I
saw people do it I didn't know what the
water was used for it that's that's one
percent true yeah they put water in that
plane I don't know what it was for
because you couldn't drink it I'm
assuming it may be for washing your
hands I have no idea I did work there it
is dangerous I framed it in a way that
made it scary as possible but I I left
gaps in to make you assume the worst
that they were doing it for nefarious
reasons I started the story by saying
people believe they do these things for
a nefarious means to start the story off
on some scary way hmm so by the time
it's done I say I can confirm this man I
watched them do it and I don't know what
they were doing or why but that stuff
can be dangerous and then the average
person walks away saying whoa dude
that's framing you know that story tell
that's the truth over facts that's right
I act there's a good point to be made
about truth over facts
all right I love that line it's funny
but I don't know if I think it's the
other way around
facts / truth right that is everything I
told you was a fact right but you know
the truth I was giving you facts to
deceive you right is the craziest thing
about how news operates so these stories
like like the story we saw about Ivanka
Trump they will tell you the truth about
certain things and connect things in
weird ways that make no sense do you
think maybe that's what Biden was
actually saying no no that we manipulate
you that we don't care that yes that's
what I'm saying what could he have
possibly meant what how did he get well
so that he heard someone else say it in
in what we're trying to talk about how
like they used the truth and the facts
to try to like manipulate us
so like the truth is what they give us
over the facts that what actually
happened so he heard it he was like yeah
I'd like that line that's good I'm gonna
use that and the debate later and then
says it with no legal sex and everyone's
like what is he talking about that's
ridiculous now now hold on hmm - Biden's
credit both truth over facts does mean a
lot yeah okay it means that you want to
really give someone an objective
reasonable understanding regardless of
the individual facts that can be falsely
misrepresenting okay to give someone a
you know so this is what this is I was
talking about the need for like an
independent aggregator and fact checker
yeah because you can have all of these
stories be factually correct but
truthfully wrong okay like when they
when they take a quote from Trump where
he says something you know What did he
say
you're a nasty guy you're a nasty
reporter and go to that one reporter fry
it NBC or whatever that is a fact but
the truth of the matter was more complex
the guy had been goading Trump on for a
while and no matter what Trump had said
he had countered in the in the opposite
so Trump snapped and called a nasty if
you really want someone to understand
what happened and why Trump said that
and the truth of the matter was actually
broad it's funny because people who
thought that with YouTube went with
digit with online video we'd have facts
to prove everything yeah and now it's
like so here's actually another really
really great example of what they've
tried doing to me
there was a story that came out
and the New York Times wrote about it
and Fox wrote about it on a live stream
I said something The effect of you know
someone said which you know which outlet
we do trust on this one and I said well
I don't trust the New York Times I do
trust the Fox story they took that I
it's fact I said it it's a quote mm the
context was about one story right so
when they take that clip out of context
the fact is I did say it and they used
the literal statement as opposed to what
was actually trying to be conveyed right
they do with Trump all the time so
that's a fact he did say that it's like
the overarching truth is that the
context behind it was like that's the
simple the simple way to look at is like
what what out of context really means my
question is do you think Biden could
even explain it
oh I think in a coma he was talking
about I think what he meant to say was
facts of her feelings that's what I came
up with I'm just not really sure didn't
make sense at the time it doesn't make
sense now I'm just glad that there's a
website about it I love it oh yeah true
there were facts so look at it this way
these people are mocking Trump for
creating a this campaign culture there
are facts because they're not smart
enough to understand it like first of
all it's obviously fake yeah very much
so it's amazing crazy amazingly fake and
you know what wait I texted that number
and they have you send send them your
zip code they're like we're gonna get
you on board we're gonna talk to you
about person Trump and then they want
you to take a survey about President
Trump so they know exactly
yeah I've seen I've seen Trump surveys
that have you seen them items it's like
hey I got it I got an email because I
used to go to the Trump rallies to cover
the 2016 15 2016 campaign season and the
emails I've gotten have been like you
know how would you rate Trump's job
performance good great the best other
yeah I'm like what other point of this
let you make people to go another way to
say they don't like it it could be
anchoring make someone click he's doing
a good job yeah and then know like the
law firm like well I think he's doing a
good job that could be it maybe I don't
know or it's just Trump you know I'm the
best you know you know it's always great
you know whatever
mm-hmm I have a question though I was
I've been wondering this we've we've
kind of broached the subject in some of
the past podcasts
is the left just becoming people who
don't they're not smart you know what I
mean like certainly there are smart
leftist so just [ __ ] rounded I see the
thing is that like you said it earlier
right the left they don't follow the
right the right they follow the right
and the left right the journalists I'm
saying so no but everyone does to like
conservatives read liberal and
conservative news yeah okay moderates
same but the people on the left are only
following their own yup circles so that
breeds like stupidity almost you know
like I can't think of a better word you
know but clinically say what I'm seeing
like if you show this website to any
rational person they'll laugh and be
like what is this yeah
you look down it says paid for by Trump
you're like what what is there making
fun of Biden it's like they didn't even
watch the video like what well there's
something that happens it's you when
you're talking to someone with an
opposing view that might be actually the
correct view and you think something
else and you you have a debate and then
you change your mind and then oh okay
you know what now we're on the same page
that's great the people on the Left they
don't like that it's it's it's almost
like you said over emotions of feelings
yeah that's what the left is they're
just a ball of emotions and feelings yes
they don't care to hear about facts or
whatever anyone else is saying because
it's triggering them and and at a raw
level you know they're like it geologic
gets thrown out the window because it's
all emotions at that point one so I have
this I this article from the rap and one
of the things they bring up it's
hilarious because they clearly have no
idea they're talking about they say
truth over facts branding is in line
with messaging from Trump
Kellyanne Conway invented the term
alternative facts like hold on truth
over truth over facts was Joe Biden's
gaffe it's not Trump's branding they
clearly have no idea they're talking
about but great fun ever yeah when the
alternative facts things happened with
Kellyanne Conway mmm-hmm I immediately
heard her say that now in okay and then
a bunch of people were like I can't
believe they believe their alternative
facts like there are what I don't
understand so if I do a study okay that
says you know coffee causes cancer
I say fact a study proves this causes
cancer and then you say hold on I got a
study that says it prevents cancer fact
a study proves cancer doesn't cover
cause cancer or suggests or
you know found if I said that a study
found coffee causes cancer
that's effect I study found that yeah if
I say a study found that coffee prevents
cancer fact a study did find that find
that yeah so you do have alternative
facts you know it's it's semantics I
guess yeah so it depends on you know who
do you trust
so immediately you know someone tweeted
this there's no such thing and I
responded with like what about
conflicting studies and there's like no
answer
well I mean that's that's really the
biggest thing it's all semantics every
thing they they have like that you know
the the whole Advanta thing it's like Oh
Samantha key can run with it and and
throw everything we can into it because
they crossed what we you know believe
it's almost alignment exam though
laughing is is emotional so they're
easily shepherded by people who are
waiting for any opportunity to falsely
like to create to create that lie give
an opportunity like when Donald Trump
said I don't know if I we've talked
about this but in 2010 that during
during the 2016 election he said Hillary
Clinton acid-washed our server right we
all know what he meant he meant that she
purged it yeah yeah
NBC said false Hillary Clinton did not
use a corrosive substance on her server
she used bleach but it's like no one
thought that's what Trump meant did you
really think that's yeah yeah yeah and
then they're catering to all the left
that are also dumb that believe that
kind of stuff I think so there's there's
a graph that I've tweeted out several
times nunca conservatives tend to read
mostly conservative news and around 30
to 35 percent is liberal news okay
moderates tend to read the inverse
around 60% liberal sources and 35%
conservative sources okay
still both liberals 95 percent liberal
sources you know I wonder if that's
actually not you know correlation but
causation that because liberals only
read liberal news they're liberal if a
person reads mostly liberal stuff but
some conservative they'll be moderate
okay if a person only reads conservative
they'll be conservative or even if they
read mostly conservative and if a person
reads only liberal they'll be liberal
it's really funny then
that you actually have conservative and
moderates mostly you know agreeing and
disagreeing on some policy issues but
like getting along yeah because that's
like the lot but then you have the
liberal faction of people who just read
the left so I wonder if over time what
we're seeing is the two groups that are
forming right so you know the walk away
campaign yeah you've got a lot of people
who are formerly Democrats now leaving
joining the Republicans voting for Trump
or just leaving the Democratic Party
yeah
over time it's like it's like watching
you ever see one of those Plinko things
you know you know Plinko is from oh of
course yeah yeah it's a it's a the price
is right where all the little pegs are
then you drop the thing and it bounces
around and if you drop them evenly they
start distributing in different ways it
feels like there are some you know some
people who are really dumb and some
people who are you know moderately smart
or inquisitive at the very least okay
and so when you drop them into this
machine where the left is fake news that
any reasonable person will question and
the right has a bunch of you know
hyperbolic conservative opinion you have
a bunch of people saying that's a lie
that's their opinion I'm okay with their
opinion I disagree I'll go read this and
then you have the dumb people being like
derp that's the truth that's the truth
so the dumb people are being filter into
the dumb section you have basically quiz
ative people are arguing over the
opinions of people right and
enlightening themselves essentially well
they're being forced to argue yeah and
that's what how you become more
enlightened well hearing other yeah well
I mean even if you end up being right in
the long run you're still you still had
to prove your point you can still go bad
I learn more about it you can still pick
up bad ideas test that's true but it's
an issue of do I blindly just believe
whatever I'm told or actually it's not
even that the truth of our facts is the
perfect explanation the perfect example
you know take two people one person is
of average intelligence moderately
inquisitive and they see this and they
go what is this like truth over facts
why does Biden look so dumb Oh Donald
Trump paid for it it's like Trump making
fun of Biden they take a dumb person and
they go do Joe Biden whoa that's crazy
whoa that that's a Joe Rogan quote
oh you know what I mean it was wage Oh
Rose what I mean is you show someone
this Ivanka new statesman article mm-hmm
a reasonable person is gonna be like ah
but she only tweeted the word taken like
what they're only 30 Elon Musk is and a
white supremacist this doesn't make
sense
no it makes let me let me Google this
and there's no other facts nothing else
looks sillier the reasonable person says
like um I'm gonna ask someone about this
did you see that story about Elon is
that true that sounds weird I don't I
don't know if I believe that then you
get the other person they go whoa she's
a Nazi I knew it and everyone that's
taken the red pills also a Nazi up I
knew that eco-fashion
yes here's the best part the dumb people
go on Twitter and they wiggle their arms
there one book and the Democrat
politician see then they go I guess
that's what they want and then people
like me and like you and like Lydia and
the walk away people are like no like
why are you doing that way being Turkey
thing the wavy turkey thing they have no
idea what's going on what they're
talking about and so you end up with
people having no choice but like if
you've got one person on the left and
it's like why should I appoint you and
they're going well I'll lie to you I'm
lying to all of them mm-hmm or it's like
they just lie to you and you're like but
you're you're lying and then you go to
the right and they're like here are my
opinions and I'm like I don't like those
opinions but you're telling me the truth
yeah they're just your opinion I
appreciate the truth right I I can't get
over how close they look together
that's hilarious for anyone who missed
this segment earlier this is insane that
they look exactly the same okay so the
author and Visakha oh man wearing a red
dress with blonde hair
hand on the chin and they do this photo
it's like the same thing she's wearing a
red dress but she but this is we should
write a whole article about how that
right there this right here all right
yeah yeah you're all right Sarah same an
event
who knew my Navis that whatever it is
Manav ease my hobbies I don't know
whatever sounds cooler it is
yeah we're Sun stupid I see ma I think
mana mana this because of Final Fantasy
is this the weirdest thing ever do you
think and here hit the big question and
we could wrap this up and jump over the
chats is it does she know what she's
doing
yeah I think the answer is yes
absolutely yeah definitely does going
through the lexicon of terms because
this article is one of those things that
all the people on the left are like oh
yeah share this man did you did you read
about that
yep shelters just stupid people to love
right that's that's crazy thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you